notre chronique médical du mercredi
maintenant avec martine à la réunion et
a invité le docteur jacques servier oui
nous avons choisi aujourd'hui parce que
l'actualité le veut le médicament
aujourd'hui 12 180 médicaments sont
moins remboursés par la sécurité sociale
ils étaient remboursés à 70% ils ne sont
plus qu'à 40% parmi eux un certain
nombre de produits contre les nausées
les vomissements les vitamines les
collyres des antitussifs contre la toux
et cetera monsieur servier tout une
question est ce que certains médicaments
de votre laboratoire sont dans la liste
où il sert tant pis si
mais si vous voulez monopinion d'une
façon générale c'est qu'il faut toujours
regretter des mesures contre le
médicament français il ne faut pas au
mieux sur
demi mesures ou mesures complètes elle
s'ajoute à 40 ans la compréhension de
notre pays et pourtant le même schéma
perçait et le deuxième du monde pour la
découverte après les états unis le
troisième du monde pour l'exportation
avant les etats-unis et le japon le
médicament français quelque chose de
précieux il faut pas trop y toucher le
gouvernement pris quelques mesures
concernant un pour donner mois
d'avril acheter quelques gentils touche
shift
gouvernement a pris quelques mesures
concernant les médicaments qui sont
déplaisantes pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique mais en même temps ils
demandent pardonnez-moi
la reconquête du marché intérieur
français et vous êtes vous même à
laboratoire typiquement à 100% français
je vous propose de voir et de commenter
maintenant quelques images de votre
propre laboratoire et de nous dire un
peu créé sa progression depuis 25 ans
malgré les chinoiseries administrative
malgré des mesures dont vous parlez
en 1947 il y avait dans votre
laboratoire neuf personnes aujourd'hui
il y en a combien maintenant 3000 on y
fait quoi exactement eh bien on y fait
surtout de la recherche parce que
n'oubliez pas le principal constituant
du médicament c'est la recherche et
l'invention tout le reste ne fait que
l'aider en médicaments ceux de la
recherche est un peu de principe actif
autour et vous vendez tout de même des
médicaments qui se vendent très bien en
france et à l'étranger et bien voilà la
moitié de notre production ses coudes à
l'étranger et ses exportations
permettent à la france de financer
l'achat de 200 mille tonnes de pétrole
donc vous rapporter à la france donc
pour apportons à la france beaucoup en
exportation et en découvertes je reviens
là malgré toutes les mesures vont s'en
trouver se porte bien il n'est pas de
chômage chez vous non il n'y a pas de
chômage et même l'emploi chez nous
augmente mais c'est beaucoup à cause de
notre expansion à l'exportation on a dit
que vous étiez un fanatique du
médicament vous y convient c'est exact
et j'ai bien dit le médicament avorter
ou mourir voilà alors vous êtes l'auteur
d'un livre justement contestataires tu
m'aimes qui s'appelle inventé ouvrir
provocateur en tout cas mais c'est en
même temps un procès d'un district vous
faites nous consacrer beaucoup d'argent
la recherche mais tout le monde ne le
fait pas
l'industrie pharmaceutique française
consacre tout de même 17 8% de ses
ventes à la recherche ce qui est
considérable mais ce que je veux
constatée surtout
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'espérance de vie est de 80
ans
au siècle dernier l'espérance de vie
était de 40 ans et l'a doublé est en
bonne partie grâce aux médicaments donc
il faut continuer il faut aller plus
loin et c'est pourquoi la recherche de
médicaments sont si importants et c'est
un talent des français ni au monde que
quatre ou cinq pays qui savent découvrir
le médicament et la france fait partie
de ces de ces pays mais c'est saviez
combien de laboratoire sont morts ces
dernières années eh bien c'est
absolument remarquable on dit que nous
sommes une industrie heureuse en 25 ans
90% des laboratoires sont disparus
beaucoup plus que dans tous les autres
pays et c'est hélas un peu le résultat
de la concentration industrielle
inévitable mais surtout de la
compréhension que nous subissons fut le
peut-être aussi parce qu'ils n'ont pas
eu l'esprit d'invention dont vous parlez
qui vous paraît tafer remarque anne
bécheau crois qu'à l'heure actuelle ce
qu'ils ne découvrent pas meurt c'est le
titre de mon livre si je veux aussi bien
depuis 40 ans vous êtes malheureux avec
les anciens gouvernements avec le
nouveau il ya une tendance constante
alourdir le carcan dirigiste et le
subissons depuis quarante ans sous les
gouvernements les plus variées il ya du
beau monde dans ces gouvernements eh
bien nous subissons
le délire le délire législatifs
c'est-à-dire des lois qui change sans
cesse des règlements qui s'accumulent et
des chinoiseries administratif
permanente avec les meilleures
intentions mais nous on est au fond vous
voulez quoi qu'on vous laisse une totale
liberté je voudrais que les
gouvernements se repose un peu ça fait
beaucoup de bien dehors du médicament et
qu'ils cessent de multiplier les lois
les décrets les arrêter les ordonnances
qui nous laisse un peu travaillé
découvrir et à ce moment là nous
reconquerrons le marché intérieur dont
nous ne tenons plus malgré nos capacités
techniques malgré les capacités
techniques des france la médecine nous
nous tenons plus que 53 % nous aurions
pu en garder 80% et nous pouvons les
récupère nous est compté bien à
condition d'inventer et qu'on nous
laisse inventé
merci docteur jacques servier